myopia is an eye condition also referred  to as nearsightedness it means a myopic  person can see nearby objects clearly  and the faraway objects not so much on  the other hand hypermetropia is referred  to as long-sightedness which means far  away objects can be seen clearly and not  nearby objects but what really happens  in the eye in these two cases when the  vision is absolutely clear and normal  the image is formed on the retina when a  person has myopia the image is formed in  front of the retina this could be  because of elongation of the eyeball a  student who isn't able to see the  blackboard for example is suffering from  myopia  and when a person has hypermetropia the  image is formed behind the retina and  this may be because the eyeball is too  short a person who isn't able to read  what's written in the notebook or  newspaper is suffering from  hypermetropia go on to share this video  with your friends  [Music]